it's been more than three years since
the horrific events of one october
but the fbi is still working to give
closure to survivors who were at the
route 91 harvest music festival
personal items left at the concert
grounds that night need to be returned
bianca holman explains the healing
garden is a place for peace
and reflection there are many items here
from those that were taken from us that
night but for those living they've yet
to receive those items left behind
the fbi worked with a company to catalog
and photograph each
item there are hundreds of things like
cell phones to key chains
that have not been returned to owners
emails and letters were sent to those
survivors on file the vegas strong
resiliency center says obtaining these
personal items will aid in the healing
process
when a tragedy like this happens they
lose that sense of safety and control
over themselves over their own person
over their
over their belongings and getting that
back gives them
a you know restores some of that control
the center is a resource and information
hub for all those impacted by the one
october shooting and it's also
very significant in having communities
do this for those that have been harmed
right it's
showing we care about you we're here for
you we're going to support you
so it definitely fosters healing if you
feel like you or a loved one have items
in the fbi's possession
you can contact the las vegas resiliency
center the center is also launching a
peer support group over the next few
months to continue to help survivors
connect with services
reporting bianca holman 8 news now